the smoke was so thick you couldn't see
you couldn't see through it you can't
see your hand in front of your face
you're hoping you're never gonna have to
face or go through fire slightly late
when area to completely shot into
darkness and then I'm no sort of lawyer
boat on the floor in the dark and with
really just the noise of the roaring of
the fire in the back
we've been so many changes since the
Kings Cross fire not not just to the
underground if you look at Kings Cross
as a place
this is King's Cross station today used
by more than 95 million underground
passengers per year and here it is three
decades ago older dirtier and more
dangerous on the 18th of November 1987
this message came through to the fire
station in Soho an escalator was on fire
it said the reality was that a small
blaze would become a disaster that would
change London Stuart bottom was one of
the first firefighters on the scene
before the inferno took hold it wasn't
until we got to the head of the
escalator number four and Piccadilly
line that we actually saw there was a
fire and it was a small fire about four
foot high and it was going quite well
but then suddenly fire swept through the
station as we align the hose out we
could then hear all the screams coming
from the entrances through the smoke
just horrible screams and you thought I
thought to myself I know there was more
people round some of that concourse
around the outer edges and not too many
people near the fire but around the
outer edges and I just thought I wonder
how many people are caught up in that I
hope they got out in fact dozens had
been caught inside among them Damon
Brodie a 20 year old who'd moved to
London just five days earlier to start a
new job
everything unraveled really quickly
probably within a fraction of a second
and there was just this huge fireball
and from my right-hand side that just
shot across the ticket hall and and it
probably baseness craters were kind of a
wall of fire that just just with a roar
and a wished I don't know that I knew
really what had going on I mean I knew
that having been on fire but I didn't
buy that point you know I wasn't
entirely set of my circumstances
or yeah or at least wasn't really
thinking I am no stuck in a fire I was
just thinking you know I really die and
just thinking well you know if I could
take a deal with anybody right now what
what would it take to get me out of you
what you know and I and I struggled with
that you know four years later which was
that kind of what what kind of deal of I
made to go if you you know found that
difficult too much lately
Browdy escaped terribly burned but alive
31 people including a senior fire
officer died this was the worst fire in
the history of London's underground as
the scale of it became clear a temporary
morgue was set up and a young police
sergeant was put in charge three decades
later Paul Crowther is now the Chief
Constable of the British Transport
Police the enormity of it I think hit
home quite early on just the scale of
the the incident itself and the loss of
life I guess the things that stick with
me whether the smells and the scene of
tired and exhausted
firefighters sat down sort of leaning
against walls taking a breather from the
the enormous effort that Corning and
thirty years ago this is exactly where
the Kings Cross fire started on the
escalator up from the Piccadilly line
now then this would all have been made
of wood and a discarded cigarette
started a smouldering fire that rapidly
took hold as the flames grew they turned
into a fireball and then we have the
flashover effect that meant the flames
came up the escalator in here into the
ticket hall where they engulfed
everything and everybody that they came
across the ticket hall was rebuilt but
it's still in the same place and the
memories live on of that terrible night
there isn't a week that goes by that
somebody in some context doesn't talk to
me about the Kings Cross fire it's very
very interesting it's part of our fabric
and we think about it all the time as
the time that we really changed and
created this brilliant world-class metal
at the time the question that followed
was why why had a small fire grown so
quickly to cause such devastation and
here's the man who found the answer
Ian Jones led a team that investigated
the cause of the blaze they modelled the
way the flames had behaved
in 1987 this was world leading research
and they discovered how a small fire
could race up a tunnel Jones and his
team used this a Cray supercomputer that
was the most powerful and expensive
computer in the world 30 years ago but
Jones's analysis was not just about the
chemical cause it was also about
something more profound about a failed
culture one of the main conclusions is
that fire safety is the responsibility
of those at the top I think that is one
of the key conclusions you can't just
pass the buck down to the poor people
who are responsible for this for the
station you have to give them the
budgets you have to take responsibility
yourself
this fire was followed by a public
inquiry that was strident in its
criticism managers resigned although
none were prosecuted and more than a
hundred and fifty different
recommendations were gradually
implemented 30 years ago Kings Cross was
a very seedy area but since the fire
it's gone through a constant
regeneration billions have been spent
turning this into one of the most
vibrant quarters of the capital but the
effects of this fire go way beyond
London our emergency services learn so
many lessons about how to respond to
major incidents our transport companies
finally took safety very seriously this
was a disaster that changed the fabric
of British life pretty much everything
you see in this great station in the
rest of our network from the training of
the staff to the relationship with the
agencies to the infrastructure itself is
different so it's fair to say it was
probably the most pivotal event in the
history of London Underground I think
back to the fact that they were smoking
carriages on the ship can you think of
that now there was no radio system that
worked underground and a direct result
of the Kings Cross fire was the
implementation of a rodeo system on
underground but so many other things the
procedures for fire evacuations the way
the emergency services work together
communications and joint training many
of the good practices we see today came
about as a direct result of Kings Cross
in 1987 the King's Cross fire was
followed by grief and soul-searching and
there is a grim coincidence that its
30th anniversary will come just a few
months after the devastating Inferno
here at Granville Tower
a block of flats just four miles from
Kings Cross station the public inquiry
into the Grenville Tower fire is due to
report that next year its remit as it
was with Kings Cross is to examine what
happened and to try to ensure mistakes
can't be repeated I attended the inquiry
at King's
and at the end of that inquiry lessons
were learned and a whole host of
recommendations were published to make
changes on the way
you know all aspects of firefighting
underground stations were made and the
same will be at Grenville there'll be an
inquiry and they need to learn the
lessons from it and for those whose
lives were affected by the Kings Cross
disaster there are echoes at Grenville
some believe crucial lessons were
forgotten some many lessons I don't
think were applied to the Grenville
disaster it was I believe a systems
issue again of individual components
behaving in one way and whether or not
it was the fireproofing that the fire
retardant panels that were fitted
unfazed are whether or not it was the
air gaps whether or not it was the
failure of the barriers the fire
barriers that were situated between
these different panels I don't know but
the whole thing should be looked at as a
system taking into account the
modifications that are made through the
building of these towers and then the
maintenance of the whole facade on these
buildings the late 1980s saw a rash of
disasters from Kings Cross to the herald
of free enterprise from Manchester
Airport to Hillsboro each was followed
by inquiries by changes and public life
became safer like Kings Cross station
our world was rebuilt and rethought and
that's one of the reasons the Grenville
tower Inferno was so profoundly shocking
we thought we'd left this behind Adam
Parsons Sky News